amara Shafi is struggling to cope she
says her world turned upside down after
her husband was arrested earlier this
year it happened at a time of heightened
tension
shortly after Muslim fighters launched
attacks in and around Sri Lanka's
capital Colombo on Easter Sunday the
family says his arrest is part of an
orchestrated campaign I didn't have my
job I I don't have a place to stay I
said less my children are not going to
school I had to face all these problems
and I have to find solutions for them
for those problems as well as the legal
I had to look after the legal aspect of
my husband as well she doesn't want to
show her face because she says the
family has received threats her husband
who's a doctor has been accused of
master realization of single e's women
he was arrested in a case that police
admit had no basis he has since been
released on bail the scandal followed
weeks of anti-muslim sentiment after the
Easter attacks which targeted churches
and hotels killing more than 250 people
it also led to a spate of anti-muslim
violence targeting homes and businesses
these events were on the agenda of the
UN Special Rapporteur on religious
freedom during his 11 day visit here
lack of pre-emptive response is
something everyone everyone know and
notes and then there are many cases in
which either because of mismatch of the
of the police available and the mobs in
question that some of these mobs we're
about to rampage on addressing the media
on Monday Shaheed said he had heard
complaints of double standards by law
enforcement authorities and about the
failure of the state to protect people
against hate crimes groups like the
Buddhist power force opodo balasinor
have been accused of carrying out
organized violence against the Muslim
community a charge its CEO denies
we have never spoken against the Muslims
in an organized manner the Buddha Buddha
seen on every occasion spoke against
Muslim terrorism that has no connection
to the ordinary Muslim community
referring to the recent violence the UN
Special Rapporteur says Sri Lanka's
government must do more to protect
minorities in order to challenge
extremism and create inclusion you
really need to have you know rule of law
well protector well rule of law is not
protected then then the weaker
communities are vulnerable to attacks
and the majority feels they can exploit
that space to the up to the advantage
Shaheed says reforming the education
system to teach respect for all
religions is important Shaheed says Sri
Lankans should work towards creating a
common identity beyond religion and race
given the country's violent past more
Sri Lankans are likely to agree if
politicians will let them win a
Fernandez al Jazeera Colombo